my crazy or is that a new shirt am I
crazy or is that a new shirt am I crazy
or is that a new shirt are you talking
to me yes okay yes it is we brought
together seven couples we are elbow and
we're couples we are we are a couple we
are a couple we're a couple a couple
we're an apple one is a liar if the
group discovers who the liar is we'll
split a cash prize
if the liar survived they win the entire
prize
you know each other's parents names
Matthew and Kerry and then her mom is
davina and her dad is Peter karma and
Patricia David and Terry everyone's
saying parents names but I don't know
what their parents names are like they
could be making something wrong I know
you've met each other's parents but like
don't other names have until needs six
months I guess but either way like they
said they were together for six months
and I thought that I would assume you
know you're their parents names by then
about biggest fight I feel like because
we work together a lot we're both in the
film industry I feel like the darkest
times I remember alike either I didn't
like something you did or like I'm
really depressed about something that
I'm doing and you're like what's wrong
with you or something my parents are
just not the most accepting cost over
that like the number at the same time
[Music]
yeah they didn't know their parents
because names they're the only one out
of all of them that were like oh yeah
you don't know and so everyone was like
we talked about when we realized we
liked each other like what was slow is
the thing that made you feel something
she used to come to a bar that I used to
run and
to give her a hard time she didn't look
21 I kept pursuing her and I don't think
I was necessarily her type in the
beginning but I definitely was
interested in you mm-hmm-hmm and I was
like I don't want to know why I cross
any line but also it's like I want to be
like hey like we're working together but
like and you're editing my short film
but also let's throw this into the mix I
wanted to be like let's not wait we
don't have to were done or something you
know what I mean yeah you met at
orientation I was a sophomore I
transferred so I had no friends that she
was a freshman and just best friends
like vibe immediately and she knew you
knew before yeah I mean like I I always
kind of knew I was Indiana and she
didn't really know until like two years
later and we just like started dating is
physical and not it's not off-limits no
it's not so kissing yeah right before
the kiss he was like all right and I was
like why would she say what did she say
all right like right before kissing I
was like whom that seems a little
suspect
okay so what's like the most romantic
day you guys have we went on a trip a
few months into dating mm-hmm up north
and soon this like tiny little cabin
went hiking in the redwoods yeah it was
very refreshing although that was when I
was like we're gonna say I love you you
did it was delayed by another weekers
as everyone hold hands yes she was
pregnant but it doesn't mean like it's
his baby oh yeah you like it could be
anyone's baby would that be a good bowl
the perfect lie yeah something that each
other would only know about each other
because of your intimacy like weird
matter isms or anything like he would I
will be in bed and I'll be like tucked
away and happy boys I mean it's good he
does the most disgusting thing he picks
out his toes and then something like
super deep to each other and I just want
to see like and look each other in eyes
so I'm super thankful for how much
you've grown since
we first started dating because I know
that Oh that your anxiety gets in a way
in the way of a lot of things but now it
really does you know I'm really thankful
now like you pushed me to do stuff like
this that way it helps me grow as a
person you are carrying my child inside
of you and that's such an amazing
experience and I would never have chosen
anyone else I'm so happy that we can do
these things together I mean I just
think knowing you for this past 16 years
I've grown tremendously as a woman and I
think you have had a huge part in that
growth social interest person but you
make me so happy
very nervous person but I'm glad you
taking out of my shell and I found that
with you I'm really thinking we're here
and I don't know it you're just like my
best friend and I'm glad like of
everything we've gone through together
and I'm super excited of like what we
can do and I just feel like as long as
I'm with you we can like conquer
everything and whatever happens we can
just do together okay you've brought out
the best in me and
I feel like I tell you this all the time
but if I didn't have you in Rhode Island
with me I don't know what I would do I
would drop out and leave because you
drowned me and said to me just think
like no matter where no matter where I
am I'm with you I'm happy and we're my
best friend so we'll be good no matter
what we're doing we're such like private
people so it's so uncomfortable for us
to go out yeah people they probably just
didn't think it was genuine when we were
talking
[Music]
[Applause]
alright I'm indignant a bunch of college
kids thought we weren't together I mean
I thought I went like a little hard on
the kiss part I went straight in for
tongue and well yeah they played
well I'll give you that
I think it was kind of like when they
said their story about the art show I
think we kind of like ate that up a
little bit good
I had like a suspicion like right when
we started because I was like oh it
could be easier like they can told you
speak like really good friends and then
like they just went out the window I
should have stuck with my gut I had no
idea like it seemed more of a show than
just a genuine connection as far as
couples it just seemed more of a
friendship to an actual loving
connection yeah does it hurt when people
are saying oh yeah we love each other to
be like know you felt we spot here we
come
yeah we're literally don't know we saw
us
[Music]